lors du festival international du cinéma
cam est envahi par une nuée de jeunes
personnes doté d'une personnalité
incontestable
elles ont contribué à la légende de
cannes
les starlettes croisent un sujet sur
lequel en tout bien tout honneur les
photographes c'est un vallon des miss de
quartier des mannequins des débutants
des inconnus qui joue les pin up devant
l'oeil des caméras il mise en scène bien
rodée dès les débuts du festival avec la
création d'un concours de nice aquarev
la starlette à la gloire tout simplement
à la consécration de ne plus être
seulement la plus jolie môme de son
quartier mais la plus belle sur la
croisette sur les champs elysées bien
bennett au hollywood bowl va le mirage
ne dure que deux semaines avant le
retour à l'anonymat
en 1958 c'est sophie originaire
d'argenteuil qui tentait sa chance
sophie morand on sait pas dans quoi elle
a tourné mais ce doit être quelqu'un
sophie qui déploie ses cheveux jusqu'à
la taille il rate tout naturellement les
mettre en valeur
sur le sable doré de la plage sophie
sous le grand soleil se contente d'être
jolie 1 et 50 brigitte bardot sera leur
modèle face aux photographes
l'actrice maîtriser parfaitement l'art
de la mise en scène
quand d'autres se faisait encore le
cinéma est à côté de ses vedettes
confirmées
en voici une qui commence à peine à
naître elle s'appelle yannick elle est
inconnue pour l'instant
elle a deux charmants yeux bleus et de
belles boucles blondes et un photographe
se prépare à la lance et probablement à
la couverture dans les plus grands
magazines français
chacune tente de se démarquer au prix de
quelques acrobaties de quelques
tatouages ou d'un effeuillage fm
petit scandale sur les marches du temple
ou des marcheurs de publicité avait
introduite une starlette audacieux c'est
l'internet qui plus cher acheté par les
marchands comme cette polonaise vis
topless 92 qui tentait sa chance sur la
plage cannoise
chaque jour quand la météo le permet
elle choisit une plage avant d'enlever
le moins discrètement possible
l'un des deux maillots de bain qu'elle
ait emporté starlette
c'est mon activité aujourd'hui mais je
crois en ma chance je serai la vraie
star le concours de miss eu souvent
abandonnés et souvent relancé pour les
50 ans du festival en 97 nouveaux
défilés et nouvelles lauréates qui ne
rêve que d'une chose ils vont faire du
bien autour de moi et bien sûr nouveau
mensonge avec le cinéma l'ouverture pour
nos miss à part les défilés de mode et
la photo est bien au moins le pourront
accéder au 7e art et en particulier pour
tourner un long métrage certainement
[Musique]